and if you're making last second plans
to go to Taylor Swift second concert
tomorrow night be careful what you're
buying resale sites like StubHub they're
selling tickets marked as unrestricted
view when they are far from it now
thankfully there are pictures on many of
those sites letting you see what your
view would actually look like as you can
see and then at last check StubHub were
listed as low as 310 dollars for tickets
as high as more than 2600 also be leery
of buying on social media where scammers
are lurking to steal your money now you
can find all of this information and
more tips on our website just head over
to 8newsnow.com